We're told that the radius of a
sphere can be measured using
the formula r is equal to the
cube root of 3 times v,
divided by 4pi, where v is
equal to the volume.
That's interesting.
Normally you have it expressed
the other way, volume as a
function of radius.
Here they have radius as
a function of volume.
If the radius of a sphere is 6
inches-- so they're giving us
the radius; they're saying
it's 6 inches.
So they're giving us that right
there-- what is its volume?
So we have 6 inches--
everything's in inches-- is
equal to the cube root of 3
times the volume-- that's what
we need to solve for--
divided by 4pi.
A good first step to get rid of
this cube root, is take the
cube of both sides or raise both
sides of this equation to
the third power.
Let's see, it's 6 inches, you
raise it to the third power.
You have the cube root
of 3v over 4pi.
Raise it to the third power.
And so the left-hand side of
this equation becomes what?
6 times 6 is 36.
36 times 6 is 180,
plus 36 is 216.
So you have 216.
And you had 6 inches here-- now
that you're cubing it, it
would actually now become 216
cubic inches, or inches
cubed-- is equal to-- if you
take the 3v divided by 4pi,
the cube root is essentially
taking it to the 1/3 power.
Then take that to
the third power.
They unwind each other.
So this just becomes
3v over 4pi.
Now, to solve for volume, we can
just multiply both sides
of this equation times the
inverse of its coefficient,
times 4pi over 3.
Times-- let me scroll to the
leftt-- times 4pi over 3.
Let me make sure you can
see what I'm writing.
And the whole reason why I'm
multiplying by 4pi over 3 is
so that it cancels out
with the 3 over 4pi.
And you have your 4pi cancels
out with a 4pi, and then you
have your 3 canceling
out with a 3.
And then you have, your volume
is going to be equal to 4pi
times 216 over 3.
We could write it this way.
216 times 4pi over 3.
And we could simplify this.
216, the digits add up to--
2 plus 1, plus 6 is 9.
So it will be divisible by 3.
That's a fast way to test
whether something's
divisible by 3.
So let's see what it is.
3 goes into 216.
3 goes into 21 seven times.
7 times 3 is 21.
Bring down the 6.
You have no remainder,
so bring down the 6.
3 goes into 6 two times.
2 times 3 is 6.
No remainder, so it's 72.
So 216 divided by 3 is 72.
So it's 72 times 4pi is
equal to the volume.
It's going to be cubic inches.
So 4 times 72.
4 times 70 is 280.
And then you have 4 times
2, which is 8.
So it'll be 288pi
cubic inches.
That's our volume.
And we're done.